game tech here again to break down the
text that drives the games we love and
we have another quick graphics settings
explainer for you we're talking about
one of my favorites and isotropic
filtering and more broadly of what
texture filtering does for your games
but before we dive in be sure to
subscribe to GameSpot for more game tech
all right let's filter the extraneous
details and get into it
[Music]
anisotropic filtering is commonly
abbreviated as AF because this setting
looks dopest in all honesty it's one of
the settings I'd recommend you
prioritize cranking up but this one's a
little more tricky to dissect so here's
an example look at this side-by-side
comparison of the prog hub area in Deus
Ex mankind divided on the left you see
the game without any degree of n
isotropic filtering enabled notice how
far there down the cobbled Street the
textures get blurrier and blurrier now
on the right we have anisotropic
filtering cranked up to 16 times the
distant cobblestones look much clearer
now let's switch over to a comparison
between 8 x and 16 x anisotropic
filtering in the same game they're quite
similar but the difference is more
pronounced the farther the distance of
the textures or sharper your viewing
angle in many cases the performance
difference between 8 x and 16 x is
negligible so you won't really lose
anything by getting a little more detail
in those far-off textures the effect of
texture filtering is more apparent when
your character is physically moving
forward in the game world without
anisotropic filtering you can see
distant lines or zones move where
surface details are basically cut off
the transition and quality of surface
textures as you're in motion can be
jarring generally anisotropic filtering
can noticeably affect frame rate and it
takes up memory bandwidth from your
video card though the impact will vary
from one computer to another so what's
happening here when the in-game camera
abuse textures from an oblique angle
they tend to become distorted without
anisotropic filtering and the farther
the distance or sharper the viewing
angle the fuzzier the texture will look
this helps lighten the workload on the
GPU since less detail needs to be drawn
on a game surfaces and it's sort of a
compromise for details that aren't
necessarily at the players focused
older PC games sometimes only offer
either bilinear or trilinear filtering
which essentially aims to accomplish the
same goal just to a lesser degree here's
an example from the classic first-person
shooter Return to Castle Wolfenstein
bilinear filtering doesn't look great
and the distance before surfaces start
to look distorted is quite short
trilinear filtering extends this
distance but surface blurriness is still
apparent so a quick tip for games that
don't have anisotropic filtering options
in the menus just pull up your video
cards control panel and enable
anisotropic filtering manually ah much
better
here's the summary to the backdrop of
half-life 2 anisotropic filtering give
distance surface textures that are seen
at an angle more clarity the best way to
see the effect is to look at the ground
a few meters ahead then compare it to
the clarity of the ground close to you
with AF off as you look farther away the
surfaces become blurry err the effect is
also more pronounced when the in-game
camera is in motion with AF on the far
off surfaces become much clearer and
look great in motion we kept this one
short and sweet but like anything in
computer graphics texture filtering is
complex so get in the comments to
continue this discussion give this video
a thumbs up and watch our other videos
on anti aliasing refresh rate vsync not
like good stuff and don't forget to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]